en el vídeo pasado ya vimos cómo
determinar el área de un rectángulo lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es ver
cómo le podemos hacer para encontrar el
área de un triángulo y vamos a empezar
con este caso de acá que es el más
sencillo cuando nuestro triángulo abc
tiene un ángulo de 90 grados vale un
ángulo recto la idea va a ser intentar
construir un rectángulo a partir del
triángulo abc calcular el área de ese
rectángulo y luego poner a abc con una
cierta parte del área del rectángulo
entonces vamos a hacer eso pero antes
déjame marcar que este ángulo mide x
vale si este ángulo mide x pues x más 90
más este de acá tienen que ser 180 de
modo que éste tiene que ser 90 grados
menos x
vale bueno pues para construirnos
nuestro rectángulo lo único que vamos a
hacer es girar 180 grados este triángulo
abc y colocarlo aquí arriba déjame hacer
eso en color verde vale entonces voy a
agarrar el color verde lo voy a poner
hacia allá aquí hacia abajo entonces ahí
tenemos una copia igualita
ángulo de 90 grados se pasa para acá
como 90 este ángulo de x aquí se pasa
como equis y este ángulo de 90 grados
menos x se pasa para acá también como 90
grados menos equis va
entonces observa este ángulo en total es
x más 90 x social de 90 este de acá
también es de 90 s x más 90 grados menos
x
entonces esta figura a bs y este punto
de acá vamos a ponerle de
definitivamente es un rectángulo y bg
abc es justo la mitad del rectángulo de
esta forma el área del triángulo abc el
triángulo abc es justo la mitad la mitad
del área del rectángulo abc de abc de y
afortunadamente ya sabemos encontrar el
área de los rectángulos déjame dejar de
utilizar otro color digamos color
naranja
entonces esto de aquí es igual a un
medio un medio de la base del rectángulo
que es b c b c b c por la altura del
rectángulo que es adeje entonces es un
medio por bc por ave vale entonces ve el
área del triángulo abc resultó ser igual
a un medio por este lado de aquí abajo
que es como la base del triángulo
por ave la altura del triángulo vale
entonces hasta ahorita ya probamos que
en un triángulo rectángulo nada más para
triángulos rectángulos el área del
triángulo es igual a un medio de la base
por la altura muy bien vamos a ver si
podemos hacer que esta fórmula funcione
para otros triángulos entonces déjame
pasar ahora a este triángulo de aquí va
y aquí tenemos otra vez un triángulo abc
ahora no sabemos que sea rectángulo pero
bueno como ya sabemos obtener el área de
triángulos rectángulos lo ideal sería
partir este en dos triángulos
rectángulos y para hacer eso simplemente
voy a bajar una perpendicular es decir
voy a dibujar una recta que va de a al
lado bc y llega aquí abajo en ángulos de
90 grados a este punto al cual llega y
le voy a llamar d vale aquí le voy a
llamar el punto d observa esto está bien
padre porque el área de nuestro
triángulo abc se partió en área de dos
triángulos el ave de y el adc y los dos
son triángulos rectángulos les va a
pintar de este color
a este triángulo de acá y de este color
naranja a este triángulo de acá vale
de esta forma podemos decir que el área
de abc en el área del triángulo a vece
que es igual al área del triángulo act y
el área del triángulo hace de que está
en color azul hace de más el área del
triángulo abc que está en naranja
y bueno como el triángulo azul y el
naranja son rectángulos vamos a utilizar
la fórmula que ya vimos arriba
esto nos queda igual a un medio un medio
la base de ac/dc de dcd por la altura
que es ade por a de y listo ese es el
área del primero y luego hay que sumar
el área del naranja que es un medio de
la base que es verde
debe por por la altura que es ade por
ade y ve aquí tenemos un medio lo voy a
poner con color blanco tenemos un medio
de ade y un medio de adele entonces
vamos a factorizar lo esto nos queda
igual a un medio de ade x c de c de más
verde le voy a poner de color naranja
más tv vale y que se dé más debe pues
cede más debe es toda la longitud se ve
eso está padre lo voy a poner con color
amarillo estoy aquí es se ve y por lo
tanto el área del triángulo abc en el
área del triángulo abc voy a poner un
poco más abajo para que haya espacio
abc es igual
un medio lo voy a poner a 100 color rosa
a un medio de aden adde x se ve también
podemos voltear lo podemos ponerlo como
un medio de cb por adeje
y una vez más tenemos que el área del
triángulo abc resultó ser la mitad de la
base aquí sería se ve por la altura que
es de la altura esa la tenemos que
conseguir de alguna forma uno la tienen
que dar vale bueno ya tenemos este
triángulo de acá los triángulos
rectángulos vamos a ver que la fórmula
también se vale para cuando tus el
vértice a queda como alejado queda con
mucho eco vale entonces para hacer para
encontrar el área de este triángulo en
términos de la base y de la altura vamos
a hacer exactamente lo mismo que aquí
arriba sólo que ahora vamos a tener que
extender un poco el lado bs
porque déjame ponerle un poco más acá
porque pues porque ahora cuando bajemos
la perpendicular va a bajar aquí a un
punto que queda afuera del segmento bc
de todas de todas formas vamos a
llamarle de y vamos a ver qué sucede
vale una vez más déjame pintar este de
color
de color azul y vamos a pintar todo el
grandote de color naranja observa que el
naranja abarca todo esto de acá vale
todo esto de acá
y vamos a pintar de color rosa el que
nos interese el abc
muy bien entonces una vez más como le
podemos hacer para calcular el área del
triángulo abc bueno pues ahora va a ser
una resta de áreas verdad bf ahora al
área grandota a la de adhb que es color
naranja
al área de i d b
tenemos que restarle el área azul la de
adc entonces hay que restar
de cee y una vez más como aquí bajamos
una perpendicular entonces el triángulo
adb y el adc ambos triángulos son
rectángulos y por lo tanto podemos
obtener sus áreas con la primera fórmula
vale entonces tenemos que poner en el
área de adhb que es base ósea
dv bueno es un medio de base o sea debe
por altura o sea de iu a eso tenemos que
restar el área del triángulo azul que es
un medio de la base que es dc dc dc por
la altura que es a de muy bien voy a
seguir aquí al lado derecho estoy aquí
es igual a misma idea tenemos un medio
de a de un medio de a de los factores
amos medio de a de x x debe menos de c
voy a ponerlo con color naranja
db - dc
- de ese es el color que quiero estar de
cee y cuánto es de hebe cc bueno pues es
esta longitud menos esta de acá entonces
nos queda igual a c b vale entonces el
área es igual es igual a un medio de
otra vez voy a poner primero se ve un
medio de cb por a de y una vez más
obtenemos que el área de este triángulo
es un medio de la base por la altura
entonces eso está padre sin importar qué
tipo de triángulo tengamos puede ser
este un rectángulo oeste o un triángulo
obtuso ángulo
en cualquier caso el área es un medio de
la base por la altura y bueno la altura
en el caso de los triángulos rectángulos
es muy fácil de obtener es simplemente
la longitud de uno de los lados pero
cuando tengamos estos triángulos tenemos
que conseguir la altura de alguna forma
o bien nos la tienen que dar
bueno le voy a dejar hasta aquí y nos
vemos hasta la próxima